hombre welcome back to new episode of
Dark Souls we arrived final Mendte at
this [ __ ] dragon in dead this [ __ ] oh
yeah he's the everlasting dragon and I
can enter his covenant that's right
ain't do me baby I dunno
it's from some of your brothers that if
he cut off his tail you get these sweet
as ax look at it [ __ ] ha ha ha ok I'm
going did I kill oh he's already today
time to wake up kids
so in this episode we're going to put
bed of chaos to sleep I don't have that
much time to record today so I just hope
we'll have a smooth day ok we are going
to the Blighttown space to the hell
Hawks of JB's vagina break it down to be
a girl man I look so beautiful
[ __ ] you I mean yeah it's pretty cool I
guess
we are back in quail eggs domain that
[ __ ] little car cat cat coming coming
enemy yes Jade Bray hello
I can't see anything seriously with this
chill in front of your face how do you
see anything really really yellow
Oh God Oh God great idea what what is
that
Oh God a poor thing I just want to put
it out of its misery you know it's about
I'm busy naked lady by this table
Oh God he didn't like that Edie oh [ __ ]
oh this should be easy
that only got bring in bring it Brittany
thanks for the skirt [ __ ] all right
cool
I didn't know that was a boss there
right so the llama went down a little
bit and now we can move forward
fantastic seriously though whatever is
going on there in that little porch I
don't want to know about it still
wearing a thong great this has to be
pretty bad to be barefooted on no no no
no not though not you
oh I'm badass now you know I grew up you
piece of [ __ ]
okay you're a little tougher I got to
really to team working against me
that sure was fun while I have a lot of
[ __ ] souls night okay this better be
worth it
that is all I'm saying I'll come on
I am regretting oh my god no okay
this is a suicide mission but Yolo
Oh God
drink more s Suzi [ __ ] I just want to
kill him it feels like popping a zit or
something those little [ __ ] are just
waiting for me
no [ __ ] they both got their eyes on me
[Music]
see I'm sure I'm going down here
whoa what the hell is that ugly uh-oh
bonfire
Oh show Chet Chet Chet sit oh come on
I hate you don't take on me oh yeah oh
really
Thanks he says [ __ ] break my weapon ban
fire
check Pines Inn disk I'm so [ __ ]
bored they're so cute they're like a
little meatball all right here we go
please be a boss in here demon fire what
I got damn it
what's the
knives belly-flopping man that's [ __ ]
kinky armor address well why don't you
just take my dick away too
I'm gonna DPS like your ass fall out of
heaven it's so easy when he does does
the belly flop in [ __ ] you
he says [ __ ] you [ __ ] bet you see
idiot Snape been fire and check ponds in
discards
I'm gonna die alone I assume the boss is
in there
how many mini bosses kind of men throw
out a man oh yeah I can summon him for
God I could do that
this for good old times sake all right
man let's rock the bed what
so many mini-bosses all that looks
disgusting look at that nice ass though
sent ETD how many demons cannot be in a
demon ass ok that seems to work
I know if you want to help out bro feel
free I don't oh I could have his tail
awesome
yeah baby oh god he did not like that
Oh God I got a ring for it that's
awesome hang in bro I got you back bro
actually no I don't sorry come on
yes oh man yeah
reduces lava damage alright cool I'll
take it let's see how by much
well pretty much everything okay there
it is
is that it's a lasso what are you doing
it don't make a penis joke
hey chief anything this key are more
broken that really can't be good whoa
what the hell is Oh what the [ __ ] what
is up with those little penis dragons
okay I have a feeling it's inside that
pipe mine got oh [ __ ] what are you doing
here we go Junior Pierce strikes again
bad meatball shame on you
stop hiding you [ __ ] meatball my god
look at this [ __ ] stop oh god what the
hell this game is just full of
atrocities what the [ __ ] is that I don't
want to find out to be honest
well let's kill oh god it's disgusting
please die what does [ __ ] name you hi
mr. meatball I see you're happy to see
me
yes Pat I love you really yeah I said
show me buzz I'm capable of live whoa
what is that oh hey man how are you man
dick he's like if you want my outfit
Kihei coming here we are again friends
you [ __ ] [ __ ] you spell snails in
the idiot I wear it better I wore it
better
this better be the bass fight if this
ain't no bass fight I don't even know
anymore
yeah hey slide into the lift sliding to
the right sliding to the left right left
right left right there she is
my beautiful I have no idea man I look
good look at got like your fingers you
might want to cut them
what is the Hayes did I find your little
secret your little baby egg what is this
Oh what
maybe I wasn't supposed to do that
oh [ __ ] I'm just gonna chill here sad
okay okay we're gonna have to run to the
other one
Oh Shay
come on damn just wanna kill it's gone
you know God oh I feel like there's a
bonfire here what what
you're not welcome get out who the [ __ ]
are you get off my game [ __ ] oh he gave
a lot of souls thanks Kirk oh god what I
didn't think they could get anymore
nightmarish but I was wrong
well here goes nothing big dent dog of
course it's poison - oh [ __ ] my ass out
oh nice yeah
oh oh that's nice
[Music]
all right I got pooped out - that's
really nice I'm give a [ __ ] let me go No
what why am i alive why I don't know how
I'm alive I don't know how I'm still
alive yeah that was worth it
boy that sure was fun let's never ever
ever ever do that again
well that's nice isn't it yeah it's been
it's been a good time I have a few
appointments I have to attend I'm really
sorry I'll see I'll see you in school
and Sunday oh no you're not a button
what the [ __ ] you're not up on Fri come
here little [ __ ] god damn it oh wow is
that I think I think I don't trust these
for one second they're gonna kill me
what what get your [ __ ] together bro bro
not fun not funny he's lost it and why
do a man I want to do it
oh he treated you it wasn't about a
fight yeah what didn't bother I was a
vampire
[Music]
why did life about my lightning died so
we're gonna have to do it deal with this
face for now at least you know you get
to do this I can't believe this
love it don't look at me like I'm an
idiot if you played it you would so the
floor resets every time that's is
fantastic isn't it
just when I make it to that bubble ah
stop stop this is really bad for me you
just paddle Oh cup stop I did weak it I
can paint your nails for you you look
fabulous in pink God God God God God
that guy yes oh I'm gonna [ __ ] kill
whatever is in here oh this [ __ ] boss
what death I don't want to leave this
place ever
this can't be good for me and oats this
is not boss
[Music]
I just want to be our friend I just want
to be our friend
why can't you be my friend why won't you
be my friend but I want you to be my
friend why won't you be
[Music]
oh okay that top part is gone
how convenient just don't talk to me
unless you're famous Yolo
[Music]
and we're gonna hi I know we have our
dear friend Tess but that doesn't mean
we can I'm gonna stab your [ __ ] heart
out
this is gonna be so [ __ ] good well
what the [ __ ]
oh that's just it well ice is nasty
okay you're officially [ __ ] with my
brain every every way possible
I hope I sincerely hope you're happy oh
but bang fire check punch in there's gas
you see my belt it's Gucci all right we
have all the souls to light the flame
the last one I'm gonna try to do the dlc
and we started off so well and we ended
up like this again alright stay awesome
bros they were like amigo watching
thanks for the support
[Music]
yeah